they say it's like going to sleep
but you're on fire
and you're paralyzed
so you can't scream
i mean that's all you got sometime you
know
heath freeman has died the actor who was
best known for his role as howard epps
on bones was 41.
i mean that's your dream isn't it
we want the same things from life
in a statement to e.t freeman's team
confirmed the news quote we are truly
devastated at the loss of our beloved
heath freeman
a brilliant human being with an intense
and soulful spirit he leaves us with an
indelible imprint on our hearts the
statement continues by praising
freeman's remarkable legacy as a son
brother
uncle
friend actor producer cook
and more quote
may his memory be a blessing to all who
knew and loved him
details about freeman's death have not
yet been revealed but friends are
pouring out love for the late actor
including actress shayna mochler who
shared these photos with freeman and
wrote that she's heartbroken over the
loss of such a solid friend
shiloh fernandez who starred with
freeman in the 2010 drama skate
skateland also remembered the actor on
instagram writing in part quote he was
the big brother i always wanted i'm so
beyond grateful for every second i had
with you you haven't heard anything yet
freeman's first acting credit was in
2001 on er
and during his career he appeared on
shows like ncis without a trace and of
course bones when i heard you were
working with booth here
i knew just what i needed
freeman also has roles in two films due
out in 2022
devil's fruit and terror on the prairie